guys need to get into it we need to be
into it we're trying to get a hundred
and fifty thousand let's go guys the
clock started clock started
bam come on man
ah Make Some Noise come on I'll be your
spotter Dennis here's oh Jayla Brown no
Halliburton Indiana
Donovan Mitchell
a true holidays
Mitchell
oh this is easy peasy they got a lot of
time left
plenty of time Halliburton nope who's
that Tatum oh
this is a staple at the end of every
shoot around in practice so this is a
practice shot
[Applause]
[Music]
where's
my guy's Spike we need him make some
noise
150 000 going to charity Make Some Noise
everybody see this is what's cool for
Spike that's right and that's the sun
right next to him who's had to endure
some of those rants that I went on back
in the day I apologize you do not
apologize there is no apology in that
hey I will say this this sun is a very
talented filmmaker just like his dad
he's seen with the camera there an up
and coming producer director the apple
does not fall far from the tree with
them too
150 Grand raise for raise the Future
Part of the charitable aspect here the
left uh the East the tires Halliburton
did he hit two of the three and the game
winner are you surprised I'm not
surprised
this is what's cool about these
practices in the NBA right I mean to
raise money you have these All-Stars
that are going to put on an absolute
show tonight and tomorrow for the game
out here
it makes it so funny 3DS you get some
shots out I was trying to but they said
I wasn't open
we never stopped yet
3D I had to hold Reggie down because he
was trying to come off a screen I was
like Reggie just stay right here